so what's we really working on YouTube
right now in this episode of coffee with
Cano we're going to be talking about
some cool new tools for getting views on
your videos we're going to be talking to
two special guests and reviewing their
channels and then looking at some of the
nuances for how do you actually get
traction right now with full length
videos with YouTube shorts how do you
grow how do you get more subscribers
what are some of the things that have
stopped working on YouTube and how can
you improve and even though these are
already scheduled there's something that
all of us can learn for how you could
apply this to your channel so that you
can grow and get traction but if we're
just meeting my name is Sean canel this
is the coffee with canel show today's
episode is brought to you by vid IQ but
a little bit more on them later and
we're actually G to kick it off right at
the top with yarn geek our first guest
um Ginger how's it going hi I'm doing
great thank you so much for having me
here oh fired up to have you on
absolutely I've been looking at your
channel and excited about what you're
doing and I've been kind of reviewing
your questions but first of all tell us
a little bit about when you started
YouTube and how things are going okay
well I started back my very first video
in
2019 and then I didn't do another video
for about nine 10 months and amazingly
enough that was my very like that's my
very best video or it's gotten the most
views uh I started right after coid like
posting regularly I would say in May of
2020 and uh oh yep there's my blankets
and um I've been posting ever since and
I've been posting a whole lot and I I
try
everything that's amazing and you've got
36 uploads 700 new subscribers 87,000
views in the last month how do your
uploads break down full length versus
shorts I I would say I do more full
lengths than shorts I
probably I think maybe five or six
shorts in the last month I do a lot of
live uh live videos I I've been doing an
interview series for with crochet
designers and uh
those those have been I I would say
under half of my total video uploads in
the lifetime of my channel are live
podast or interviews what have
you and what would you what's your goal
right now to do this full-time how are
things going as far as
monetization I yeah I would I am
actually doing this full-time
fortunately my I am stay-at home now I
finished raising seven kids
so wow this this is like very little
work compared to what was before but but
um I yeah I would love to make a good
you know a good income with it I'm
having problems with I I don't really do
a good job at selling myself or selling
products which I'm working on I'm
trying so where do where does the
current income come in from ads ad
Revenue mostly I do have some affiliate
affiliate sales on yarn like on share
sale and uh you know but you know couple
couple hundred dollars a month that's
that's helpful and uh but yeah mostly ad
Revenue this is great and um if you were
to articulate kind of your best way of
saying the question what would be your
number one
question um I have so much that I'm
doing with yarn on my channel I have a
hard time focusing and I really need
some guidance on maybe what to focus on
as far far as you know I know what my
best videos are like my going yarn
shopping and things like that those get
the most views those get the most
revenue and I've been trying this
interview series that I had one last
fall because crochet season is fall
season and then I started one this fall
and I've been I don't get a whole lot of
views on the actual interview
but I think maybe they will in the
future and I've been doing them in in
hopes to break them down into smaller
videos and I have broken one down into
smaller videos but there's only so much
time in the day you
know amazing well in just a second I I
want to do a video review and we'll look
at maybe um some of the things we can
improve with one video but a first a few
initial thoughts you bring up a really
good point about interviews in my
opinion
interviews across almost every Niche are
never going to
perform anywhere close to as well as
long form
intentional
edited content that efficiently serves
the
viewer because the nature of an
interview with the exception of
celebrity guests with the exception of
being Joe Rogan building up a bigger
brand and and an audience that like
loves what the content
is the idea of listening to
a um interview with somebody that's kind
of information based with Divine Derby's
who went an hour and 28 minutes you just
want to think about the context of that
if I'm not commuting or maybe while I'm
doing my crafting I'm listening to it
passively it's kind of entertainment
like whatever it is and I think that's
okay but I want I share that because I
want you to temper your expect
expectations in our community we talk
about video podcasting all the time we
talk about how it's blowing up and some
people go no I think that other stuff's
going to go more viral I'm like no it's
not that it's going viral I think it's
the fact that it's a sustainable content
format that may lead to a business
result if you have if you have something
to offer
but success is obvious in this case in
terms of views I don't think they will
get more views that is my opinion I
actually think that they'll stay the
same
um it'll it'll it's kind of a DI hard
Super Fan they're looking for
information I think where I would turn
my attention
is
where specific topics to me obviously
Walmart has done very well you're you're
on the influence of Walmart meets other
people that would go Shar shop there so
clearly you've doubled down on that to
me one of our big next steps is doing
research and and starting here tell me
what your research process is like and
what kind of tools you're
using my research my well I go a lot
into my analytics and I would say that's
my number one is that I go into my
analytics I see what's doing well and I
also watch a lot of other yarn um yarn
videos yarn U yarn channels
and see what others you know other yarn
and and crochet people like to watch so
that that's it pretty much um yeah but I
think analytics for sure is great so a
couple thoughts let's hit this topic of
research and then we'll review a video
and research for the purpose of coming
up with great video ideas I
think that one of my favorites that we
talk about a lot it's also the simplest
and fastest and easiest is just to take
your topic and type it in right you have
yarn and then you've got what are people
interested in I clicked yarn shopping
which also it's not just the predictions
then like you said you watch others I
think there's a lot of things that would
be interested come yarn sh come yarn
shopping with me or new budget friendly
Yarns how could you maybe do something
similar of course what we're learning
there this 10 places to buy yarn online
gets me so excited
because crochet for beginners have
places to buy a yarn online and the fact
that it's online
Tony is articulated in the title itself
meaning the viewer has the intent of
purchasing yarn online which means that
they it would be logical and easy to go
to these 10 places and all 10 of these
is an affiliate link I also I always
like to think about this we start with
reverse engineer in our Sr system what
is that we want to happen well I'd love
to see my audience serve I would love to
see uh more income and so have you done
a video of uh like for example 10 places
to buy yarn online yet I have not but
now I will I that I that's a great video
to make next in fact I've had people
asking for online yarn videos so I love
it and then one of our goals is to also
think what can happen in the research
phases is you come up with lots of great
ideas but then there's almost like
should have an internal scoring for them
and what I mean by that is okay now I
have 50 video ideas from the YouTube
search bar I've got I could do a a haul
but the internal scoring and I just off
the top of my head like how I would
score it and what I mean is is this
video a one out of 10 that would mean
not great or necessarily worth making is
it a 10 out of 10 I should make this
video next is the video something my
audience has been asking for they've
been you just said they've been asking
for it that's like a 10 is the video
possible for me to make do you have the
answers to the
question you do okay so that's also
because if it's like I have to research
for six years to become an exp well I'm
probably should have make that that's
going to be a little too
hard uh oh something froze on
here
is it frozen
in
uhoh
am hello how are you what happened I was
thinking oh my gosh what have I done we
did lose Sean for just a m moment but
here we are we're still we still got you
on so um I actually wasn't fully
watching your guys's episode but um let
me know what you guys were talking about
and I'll just we'll chat a little bit
while he's reconnecting okay sure we are
talking about my channel and yarn and
well you know yarn videos oh we've got
him back okay good you don't have to
give for the full recap then here we go
blue screen to death literally hard
crash but here we are streamyard is nice
because it's web based and uh which just
keeps us live so yeah that's wonderful
that usually happens to me Smash like
everyone for for the crash and for
coming
back I appreciate you I'm glad I'm glad
uh it worked and and it's nice to the
stream's holding strong so we're talking
about um we're talking about research
process scoring it so your audience
desires it 10 out of 10 you uh
um easy to make 10 out of 10 and then
the the money-making opportunity so I do
think it's it's smart to score your
videos on money-making opportunity is
there affiliate programs that is there
um is it going to be good for ad Revenue
that could be related to this forgive me
my internet connection I don't know if
it's fighting because my computer's
restarting and melting underneath um but
is that making sense oh yeah that makes
that makes a whole lot of sense and I
think what I've I've been putting a lot
of pressure on myself for these
interviews this interview series and
breaking them down and everything like
that and I I don't want to stop that but
do you think maybe I'm P putting a
little too much focus on that I think
you are because yeah I think okay yeah I
would I think this actually might be you
know if we're just talking really
raw video podcasts and interviews are
lower effort
content they just I mean it's one of the
things I do and and it's not because of
a lack of effort it's because my effort
I don't have seven kids that I'm done
raising I have a one-year-old a
three-year-old I've got uh I think media
staff I'm wearing the CEO hat so I'm
asking myself things like sustainability
so the podcasting model is sustainable
but make no mistake me sitting down like
I just did an AI video over on our main
channel it's blowing up right now 36,000
views but it's like just it's non-stop
going up well me sitting down down and
architecting an 8 minute video is a lot
more powerful than a 90minut
unstructured conversation it just is
going to add more you know viewers uh
you know impact to the audience so to to
to we're on the same page but what I
would recommend is exactly what you said
um I would I would maybe shift away from
the interviews I would do more
structured videos and I think we found
the one related to yarn shopping let's
go after a couple other ways of
identifying um some videos that you
could uh come up with I think
that uh let's let's check out some
inside of vid IQ and um we'll go basic
on the AI coach and I think let's see
what it comes up with for us
so what are good video ideas for a yarn
Channel
use any tools like this I have I've used
vid IQ and I used Tu bu I haven't used
vid IQ for a while just because I was
Finding to buy um I was just finding
that more useful but I have noticed that
a lot more things have been added to the
whole viit IQ toolbox lately yeah and
and I the Reason by the way I turned off
the I went to the main AI coach is just
because the other one's actually
connected to think media I'm just asking
general questions here to the AI and the
cool thing about vid IQ not just because
they're sponsoring this video but the
cool thing that about vid IQ so you know
how it works behind the scenes is it's
not just chat GPT it leverages chat GPT
but they've layered programming and
thinking on top of it to like be a AI
assistant for YouTube channel so it
makes it very powerful in time in terms
of you know as a YouTube coach here's
some ideas so you have yarn huls and
unboxing yarn storage and organization
tips but here's what I like to do is
which one of these stands out to you the
most yarn Hall and unboxing young
storage and organization tips reviews
and comparisons crafting tutorials
product showcases which one do you like
best oh yeah well I've done all of them
and I I probably like the yarn haulings
and unboxings but also the storage I've
gotten the most I I get a lot of
responses for those and a lot of
Engagement okay perfect so here's what
we can do and if anybody wants to try
this out too you can go to vid iq.com
thinkink um
and there there's also a link if you
want to to try the vid the the vid IQ AI
coach for
free um there
is a link to it yeah if you just go to
vid iq.com
chat you can try this out and no cost I
don't think or anything so anybody
watching this if you just want to try
chat GPT for YouTubers basically it's
really cool um but inside of the boo
plan here's what we're going to do we're
going to go AI title
recommendations we're going to go yarn
Hall and
unboxing so to me this is this is where
the opportunity is for you I think what
we clarified was
one I think less interviews and you
already said they're they're not getting
a ton of views and I think they'll get
more in the future I don't I don't think
they're bad but I just don't think
they're best I think specific videos if
possible that can be connected to more
monetization um and then I love taking
something from say the coach the topic
and plugging it into titles before you
press record to look at some inspiration
around
maybe the Dark Side of
yarn unboxing in a hall is there a dark
side of yarn Jer oh there oh there can
be I can tell you stories but maybe that
that might be a great video see like
that's like and that's all happening
from using tools but also is based on
your expertise I don't know you know um
right and so then you could hit refresh
and there's so much idation and what's
so powerful is when you're very clear on
exactly what the video is about ahead of
time with like the exact title then you
can build out a nice structured uh video
so then what I'll also do is we could go
yarn storage and organization tips and I
think these would be they're not only
very good for ranking and search based
but I think that these are good for just
more General uh views avoid yarn chaos
with these essential storage tips uh
organization hacks transform your
crafting space genius yarn organization
hacks see I sometimes this is so many
characters in front I would almost this
forward title is is
incredible
and you could add the number ahead of it
10 okay 10 genius yarn organization
hacks and then the video
just and I I actually got one Amazon
just sent me uh some stuff that I need
to do a review on for yarn organization
they're like folding compartments which
would be I think a great affiliate sale
yeah and one of my favorite things to do
with affiliate sales is do a value based
video like 10 genius yarn organization
hacks number one free number two free
number three this thing I got from
Amazon Link in the description down
below number four a DIY thing I
repurposed number five this DIY thing I
got from Joanne Fe like or or not DIY
meaning just to give a great experience
from the viewer it's like the whole
thing is not a commercial or only
possible if you buy
something but there's there's lots of
Genius organization hacks and some of
them are like this thing is so cool and
it's very affordable and then it's an
affiliate link so because again if it's
like thing you know tip number one buy
something tip number two buy something
tip number three buy something then you
may not even but if you're like well
this is really cool like I could do that
that first one was amazing of course
leading with really with value stick
around until the end of the video
because I've got even better genius yarn
organization hacks coming
up
okay now I have a question about the vid
IQ um I and I got chat GPT and I've got
the plugins I got the paid for version
uh now Does vid
IQ tailor it to your channel like to my
specific Channel more so like maybe I
should get vid IQ instead of the paid
for jat gbt and all the plugins and
stuff yeah if I was picking one or the
other I'd rather have vid IQ because
it's leveraging chat
gp4 tailored to your channel so okay to
be clear if anyone who wants to check
this out vid iq.com think but let's I'll
show you with the AI
coach and I'll show you with the diamond
there the advanced so this is based on
my channel what video ideas do you have
for me so obviously this can only answer
think media where this is connected but
it's analyzing the data on the channel
and this you know people wonder well I
could do all my research and come up
with this well sure but how valuable is
your brain power and your decision
making and looking at Big Data and all
of that so basically look at what vid IQ
is teeing up for me here the ultimate
YouTube growth guide 2024 a
comprehensive guide latest tips
strategies and tools it tells you even
what the thumbnail could be around 15
minutes there's something powerful about
50 it's it's a really good advice
because watch time I'll make a state
statement longer videos are better what
do you Sean what do you mean by long
we're actually releasing a conversation
with do it on a dime Katherine from do
it on a dime and she by long we mean
over eight minutes and in that 10 12 15
18 minute range and the video is dense
she does a lot of videos like $36 store
finds I think it'd be fascinating if you
had a 15minute
video that was really dense with lots of
hacks or tips or cool
tricks and people got to watch the whole
thing very lucrative ad revenue is
multiple ad spots the video could do
very well because watch time you can
only get so much watch time on a four
five minute video so there's something
about it being longer now there's also
Ultra there's an argument for Ultra long
but that's what I mean by long so all
that's to say anyways is this is vid IQ
plugged
into think media 10 tech gadgets of 2024
you could bet that's coming up
especially as we enter the um the
holidays you know I think we have Kyle
on the back end here he's he's the
producer of think media now because
we're kind I'm more focused on the
podcast Channel I'm obviously there too
but we have Omar and Nolan this word
gadgets is a little bit of a different
kind of almost off brand for us because
we go more cameras we go Tech accessor
accessories camera tutorial mastering
the basics how I gain 2.6 million
subscribers on YouTube really great and
title that's like title perect
a personal story sharing your Journey on
YouTube so anyways that was just the one
prompt but um there's uh video strategy
can you audit my channel and this is all
tied directly into uh vid IQ so yeah in
my opinion um and I know that it's we're
kind of meta here because obviously
literally vid IQ is sponsoring this
video but the value I would say also the
value for someone like you that's
already monetized I think everyone two
groups of people everyone should use vid
IQ because it's free there's the Free
level you could use vid IQ Vision sign
up get it plugged in you could try out
vid iq.com chat so that's like a
no-brainer but once money starts coming
in this would be my advice for all
things even if that money is small
reinvest in the channel and that
reinvesting in the channel is like would
I be able to edit a lot faster if I had
a new laptop could I use software to
help me go even faster if I improve my
camera quality or my set of of course
also those Investments are tax write
offs and all that that's fascinating um
but it's all about how could I use tools
to help me grow faster so assuming
money's coming in it becomes a no brand
I know for some people they look at vid
IQ boost I think 50 bucks a month and
it's like well I don't have money well
there might not be the season for you to
invest in that but for the more once you
start having money coming in it's a
no-brainer if it could for sure could it
help you make another
$50 on the other side of any one of
these tools whether it's
um daily ideas and again this is another
one that's customized to you based on
analyzing your channel personalized for
your channel based on view
recommendations and the power of that
kick it over to the title guide to
optimize it you know analyzing your
competitors is fascinating for me
because I've built out this whole list
but what's really cool about it is you
can dive in and see which of their
videos is doing well what other channels
is your are your subscribers Subs ring
to and this YouTube has some of these
features but um not really in the same
way they've got that one section where
they show you right uh other channels
that's very valuable as well but it's a
little bit different so anyways I think
that that's um something to consider
we're going to review a video but any
other questions as we get ready to
transition to Matthew after this video
review um I just was uh wondering about
my memberships and if you have like a
recommendation for membership platform
thing like that because I've I've got
memberships going um I just I just uh
you know I always want to keep making it
better and that's a good question I
think YouTube memberships is a is an
interesting question pros and cons pros
Simplicity you're already on YouTube
they're already
there ease of integration in the whole
system monetization already connected so
they can easily pay you if you build
heavy on YouTube super chats can come
your way during live streams ad Revenue
can come your way Channel membership
money can come your way pretty cool cons
30% they take
30% cost of doing business I suppose
because they give you all those features
but let's say you built a huge community
and got to 10,000 a month they'd be
taking 3,000 a month are you willing to
pay that then the question to ask
is the further you go down the road with
a tool the harder it is to leave the
harder it is to transition and there'll
probably be some loss you Pros maybe you
get more channel members because the
people are already there there's more
less friction they just sign right up on
YouTube and if you went somewhere else
where you keep a higher percentage
then you actually have less people and
it's a wash
not my conviction but could be true so
these are just it's a personal thing for
you to consider there are of course
patreon types of places and that's you
know 5% and 10% um that's a big
difference at scale so these are these
are things to consider my friend Emily
Baker the law nerds she's all in on
channel memberships at scale and she's
this
all we could unpack this conversation a
lot of layers deep in fact this would
make a good F media podcast because it
goes into also the what are you
committed to and and should you be
committed to that I support our
community thinking about how they can
serve love on connect with and add value
to their channel members or anybody
subscribed to any kind of membership
platform but I also would issue a lot of
warnings the problem with the creater
economy is
things you you your lifestyle business
destroys your lifestyle pretty quick if
you let it get out of control I'm making
promises to everybody I got interview
shows to do I got videos to make I've
got Channel member q&as to fulfill on
I've got things to update I've got all
this stuff so the de sometimes the
deeper question is what is it you want
to build what can you
sustain what when is the right time to
do certain things in your business uh
Creator economy business conversations
like when could you hire an assistant so
how could we get you what's the short
shortest path to revenue so you could
hire somebody to assist you on some of
maybe the day-to-day tasks of managing
the channel so that you could show up
for these q&as but the way you serve
your members is supported by the fact
that you have kind of a in a way a
social media assistant and admin
assistant that makes that more
sustainable perhaps one of the things
that I've I've done that's been semi
Smart in my career is a as look down the
road and avoided
things by thinking about the second
order consequences of making certain
decisions maybe the reason I got that
wisdom is because I made the mistake in
the first place at one point we had a
program called Inner Circle here's the
problem with it it was so great every
single month people was was getting like
a training we had a whole separate
Facebook group there was all this stuff
it was really great but eventually was
like man we're doing our video raik
Academy program and we're doing Inner
Circle and I'm trying to keep up with
content and I'm still trying to still
grow as a leader so I may have just
turned your question into more confusion
before Clarity which isn't always a bad
thing because it's like shoot that
wasn't like a simple answer I don't
think it is a simple answer I think
there's a lot of things to consider
there does that make sense oh that makes
perfect sense and in fact that's one of
the things I'm going through right now
I'm just a oneperson
channel and so I'm running into a lot of
it seems like I'm bashing my head
against the brick door because or brick
wall because it's like oh I just don't
have time to do that you know it's it's
and you want to make everything as good
as you want it to be it takes time and
then that that time takes away from
other times so yeah no you saying that
is really really helpful so I want to
transition into Matthew actually we'll
do you know uh maybe a video review on a
future um a a future time I I hope
there's been a lot of value here but I
do have final One summary prescription
for you okay in light of our
conversation just to and and everybody
listening I think that this is true for
most and a lot of us can can lose this
formula if you will
but it's but this is also personalized
for you Ginger because of your season
you're in so it's great you're focusing
on this fulltime that is clear it's
great some money is already com in you
also have a lot of videos under your
belt over a thousand videos 15,000
subscribers I got a tweet the other day
in X I suppose from somebody that said
we need more advice for mid-level
creators you're you're doing incredible
you're like a mid-level Creator you've
got great results a lot of
knowledge you've proven to be able to
post videos you've built a lot of
momentum
and I would argue you're also already
living the dream um because the many
would dream and pray to be where you are
but like the
prophet famously said and
Scholar Notorious BIG he said Mo Money
Mo Problems and maybe it's not mo money
but it's Mo it's Mo videos you know more
Channel growth more things to do more in
the you know you got Channel membership
set up like more more viewers more
subscribers like it it it produces more
problems so I think maybe the one two
three plan is Step number one how can
you act what can you stop doing what can
you actually slow down on and I think we
identified interviews maybe not sto
completely but like what is busy work
that has added into your career every
mid-level Creator needs to know this
what have you said yes to
up into this point like even your amount
of uploads is a one person 36 uploads as
one person I mean I know you're doing it
full time it's crazy like that's like
how many thick media does it's really
it's cool but my question is could if
you did less at a higher quality now
with all that all of your knowledge and
a little bit of higher level strategy
what could you stop down or slow slow
down because you need more time more
strength willpower mental power and more
strategy step number one step number two
identif identify what is your shortest
path to increasing Revenue as quickly as
possible I think what's interesting in
your case is you're like three feet from
gold you're a few strategic videos away
definitely some hard work from a 5k plus
a month business is that more than
you're making right now oh yeah that's
yeah that's quite a bit more yeah no you
5K a month is a few moves away
right but it's like before just adding
more because it the worst thing you
could do is add more too okay to do 5K a
month I should also make a core well you
already got Channel memberships and
videos and Li and interviews you're
doing and stuff so Step One how can I do
less and and what can I say no to step
two what is the shortest path to revenue
my answer to that question is some of
the really amazing videos we just talked
about about 10 places to buy yarn online
but the video really
architected um and uh the organization
hacks one maybe 17 genius yarn or
organization hacks really good video
with Affiliates and and then key let's
blow that video up and get a lot of AD
Revenue over eight minutes at you know a
couple multiple spots let YouTube
optimize for that is usually what I do
and then a couple of those points are
are affiliate links all 10 of the online
shopping places are logically all
affiliate links because they're all
online and they all have affiliate
programs and that is exactly what the
person wants it's not weird it's like
they're looking for places to shop for
yarn online and so then in videos like
that Affiliates goes up ad Revenue goes
up Channel goes up and you're able to
devote your energy to more growth more
brand and more income and then number
three is in the process of doing
this I think it's about Relentless focus
and the killing of distractions not just
saying what am I going to stop but also
you need a plan to interrupt your
interruptions you need a you need to
look ahead and say what causes me to
usually get off track where what's
stealing my energy right now or because
if you implement this three-step
prescription but you only do these next
two videos and then you're like oh but I
just heard about this thing and this is
what happens to all of us on the
internet shiny object syndrome is
everywhere so we see this thing over
here this thing over here so it's like
make a simple plan shortest path to
revenue and then work the simple plan
and then it's don't get distracted from
The Simple Plan um for the next six to
12 months and I think that 5K a month
plus but I think in 12 months at the
long side I think in six or less months
you could close that gap on the other
side of working the simple plan but
being
really disciplined about protecting your
focus and focusing on the levers that
move the needle for your channel we call
them ipas income producing activities
okay which would be making those great
videos how has this been helpful Ginger
oh this has been extremely helpful this
has given me some focus and thank you so
much Sean this is great I appreciate you
so much thanks for coming on coffee with
canel all right so we're g to let Jinger
go we're gonna have Matthew come on here
in just a second but friends we went
through a cataclysmic crash earlier blue
screen to death Midstream but the cool
thing about streamyard is it's web based
so it just kept going Melissa jumped on
Smash like I'm curious your aha moment
from this last conversation what do you
need to do next remember the coffee with
Kel Show as we talk to our guests is
actually all about you it's all about
helping you reach your YouTube goals
we're on a mission here at think media
to help one million purpose-- driven
people create a full-time living doing
what they love while making a difference
in the world with YouTube and so all
these these conversations whether it's
researching video ideas whether it's
getting clear on what do you need to say
no to what is your shortest path to
revenue your simple money plan and how
what is your plan for interrupting your
interruptions so that you stop getting
off track and getting distracted so you
work your plan until it works and
produces the financial targets you're
going for maybe it was a Nuance of
structuring a video we were using vid IQ
today's stream is brought to you by vid
IQ we discovered a super good video idea
genius yarn organization hacks something
about powerful short titles like that
really value based Punchy you're one
video away coffee with canel from having
significant impact in terms of 10 Xing
the biggest views video you've ever
had um earning a ton of money on ad
Revenue Crossing 4,000 watch hours and
getting
monetized um and so coming up with your
next best video idea is a big goal and
then let me hit one question here and
then we're going to do some questions
after our next guest
Matthew
so Bruno asked a brilliant question we
we made a statement earlier and if you
got a question put four question marks
before and
after that interviews are
inferior to intentional strategic edited
videos unless you have access to famous
celebrity guests your Joe Rogan your
other people Sean are you saying not do
interview shows or video podcasts that's
not what I said I don't nobody heard me
say that this may be the context you
added okay but there but you sitting
down and architecting a really great 8 n
10 11 12 minute video compared to a 90
minute talking head conversation to
totally different
things if I argued the opposite side too
it'd be like but a a 45 minute 90-minute
conversation is a really good experience
in audio when you're walking your dogs
taking your kids out I'm I always got
some earbuds in and I'm listening to
some type of a a Content I don't need to
watch and study as much it's more
conversational so every kind of content
format has a time in place but if we're
looking for growth especially what we
saw on Ginger's Channel with interviews
kind of being capped at a thousand views
if I it was 90 minutes interview and the
energy of scheduling that versus sitting
down and
doing 10 17 genius yarn organizational
hacks edited super well with affiliate
links I'm gonna pick the hacks a hundred
times out of a hundred you know like
because and I love both so hear me my
mind you Bruno brought up an incredible
question that's why I love that this is
a you know a
convo but what about interviews with
subject matter experts Lo Ed with Boll
it's a really good point and there is a
separate content
format
where I might even call that not an
interview I would call it a
collab
and for
example our think
media
videos
are
interviews are what you're saying Bruno
and I it's different than like a long
form streamyard video podcast so here's
the example so
Omar interviewed Roberto Blake let's
watch the video
wait when you promote anything when you
wear any logo when you use any product
publicly when you give advice to your
friends and family and you say anything
kind about a brand you're working for
free you got to just press record man
I'm so excited to get into this
conversation so what do we see here 12
minutes and 25 seconds
b-roll
fastpaced um specific promise 63,000
views now mind you this channel is
bigger than our podcast Channel but
these views this is outperforming my 30
minute video podcast two different
things for two different contexts so
what about interviews with subject
matter
experts I would enage Ginger with this
and anybody watching as well I think
it's a whole different approach if let's
say you use something like this
streamyard perfect Record local record
which means it's going to be nice 1080p
not a little bit lower res like this
live
stream and you made a Google doc and you
brought on a guest and you actually
envisioned a video where like they're
teaching and you knew that they'd be
showing stuff think about this imagine
if you asked them to to send you a
Dropbox folder of footage of them
working in their environment so Ginger
could actually have a guest on and say
Hey I want to have like an 18-minute
conversation could you also send me some
footage could you
also well we've just completely altered
the content format but by all means I
mean my answer Bruno is yes like that
that would be in a way the same thing
that I'm arguing is for more editing
more crafting
um and another way to put it would be if
you took a 90minut conversation and made
it 22 minutes of the most powerful
moments and enhanced it in any
way that's going to outperform just the
90-minute conversation typically again
depending on who the person is so
absolutely and I think if you bring a
subject matter expert in and if you can
enhance it with video editing Boll them
demo demonstrating things we are living
in a world where you can collab
virtually
you
can film at a high quality with guests
and build out videos so if Ginger also
was like let's talk about your best
organization hacks she could interview
from somebody and then see I don't know
if the person would do it could you just
4k on your phone or 1080p on your phone
give me
b-roll of your organization place you'd
be like Outsourcing asking someone to
make you a video for you kind of you
know but if you collab in such a way I
hope this is this brainstorm is given
some of us ideas here at coffee with Cel
it's a really good question and uh
that's definitely a different way to
approach it I'm going to hit one Super
Chat and then we'll go to Matthew love
your advice but it's so difficult on a
kids channel experimenting with AI at
the moment I love it but is it
worthwhile as long as I can reach a
wider audience it's all worth the effort
uh appreciate the Super Chat I need you
to listen to the brand new episode of
the think media podcast and I need Steph
who could probably hear me in the
background need to cut this clip
because Matt
gillan's newest video
podcast um what is it probably during
like the last 10
minutes I would
say about 21 minutes in here let's see
what what we're saying advertisement so
I was having a yeah right um so I was
having a debate with someone and they
were talking about like the their app it
was a kid focus app like oh yeah we
don't want to have products you know no
toys and we want to have this vertical
which is science and learning so this
whole last convers this whole
conversation and Steph we've been
talking about this hope Steph's here
Drea can pass this along um is in my
opinion too we're doing some clips on
this channel that are like two minutes
three minutes we I want to do like 12
minute Clips it also one of the
weaknesses of this video podcast you're
learning some strategy is that why
videos you know fail in the first minute
and how to win instead
really this hook like the what is
Promised in the title of this video
podcast is answered in the first 15
minutes great it's fine I mean it's
doing very well it's it's like two out
of 10 it's fine um but the whole 18
minutes or 22 minutes we talk about kids
content in depth for by the way I don't
own any kids channels for example so I
know some but Matt has a couple kids
channels he's he's
a he's an a agency so he works with
different creators so if you're a kids
Creator kids content creator targeted
content for people under 13 or whatever
it is um go check that out and that's in
the most recent and you would never know
so then now you're seeing a little
inside thick media podcast strategy is
I'm saying Steph what is it uh this is
also information that I don't think
anyone else on the internet has so this
clip from like 16 to basically the end
will end up being about a 14 minute
video we'll upload that separately so
that we also get the search base and the
the positioning base of that but also so
that that can be found and mark my words
may I make a prediction on the other
side of executing this I actually
believe this clip about uh kids content
you're like in the midst of where the
sausage gets made right now I've never
done this before but it just like
shouting out directions can we add this
in Monday um Drea and put this so this
um I bet this the kids clip does better
than the original podcast just because
it's a topic thing and that's a
underserved topic so I hope that helps
that you can skip right to it anybody
watching this can obviously go watch
that now and then probably in the next
10 days that'll also be a clip on this
channel so you could skip right to it
with its own unique thumbnail all right
smash the like button sip your
coffee I had a meeting run late so I
haven't made my second cup of the day
probably good you
know out here uh drinking water what are
you drinking shout me out where you're
watching from lots of good questions
have come in so we're going to get to
those in just a second but first we got
to go to Matthew Miller so let's bring
Matthew on the show Welcome to uh coffee
with Chanel Matthew how's it going uh
good how are you I'm doing great thanks
so much for being here you sound you
sound fine for this interview but I want
to say that I don't think your mic's
connected um is
this I think it's the webcam
mic oh in my settings it says that it
that's the right
one no worries we can do it but if if
you end up
um maybe that's also it definitely
though it doesn't sound like it has that
Clarity of of being close to mic sounds
like the mic is you
know well I'm I'm not really sure um my
settings inside this app say that it's
the right mic but it's not the green bar
is not going up and down as much as it
should I don't guess yeah yeah yeah that
makes sense like the green bar is
probably the webcam on top of the TV or
the internal PC mic or
something we can roll with it either way
um I'll
come or I was gonna say I could come
back to you in like two minutes I'll
answer one more question yeah you can do
that and I'll try to see what's going on
all right cool so we'll roll with uh
Matthew he's building PCS this going be
a cool combo here in just a second but
let's hit our next question culinary
Crafters I've been watching all your
series on channel growth and videos
about creating hooks how do you go about
creating a hook for a cooking and baking
video by the way I use your vid IQ link
appreciate that
and so if you want to create a hook for
a culinary arts or a cooking video one
of the first tips is Show and
Tell always imagine what is the the
desire of the person clicking on this
video is it they want to lose weight is
it they want to draw better and achieve
a finished result of an incredible
drawing or painting is it they want to
learn a new make makeup technique and
learn how to Contour when you think
about a lot of videos like cooking or
makeup or
art you're oftentimes wanting to show
the final result and tease the process
and the final result
so they're being teased as to where
you're going to take them in a makeup
environment this sometimes the powerful
thing is even showing right at the
beginning no makeup versus final result
and you're like whoa I need to stick
around to see the steps to achieve that
so if you're doing a baking video I
think a hook could
be of course Show and Tell teasing all
those things the second
tip is is articulate and give reasons to
watch until the end so I think it's one
thing if I'm doing a baking video and I
was really architecting
it I would have music playing I would
have visuals what are people seeing and
I would also have a architected scripted
voice over most
likely saying a little bit of relatable
fall season always gets me excited for
pumpkin pie and in this video I'm going
to be sharing my Grandma's favorite
recipe using minimal ingredients or
budget ingredients so I'm just thinking
about powerups gonna be taking you
through the steps and then here's the
blank here's your fill in the
blank and make sure to watch until the
end of the video or make sure and watch
um until the whipped cream part and a
little bit later on in the video You're
GNA want to see where I break down how I
make the most velvety fluffy tasty
whipped cream not that terrible
store-bought stuff but using this secret
that my grandma literally whispered in
my ear when she was passing away on her
deathbed that got weird but like talk
about story you know the final thing
that my grandfather did was he unrolled
a scroll and he said son this is where
the gold is
buried and I'm going to be revealing
that to you in this video and stick
around until the end if you want to know
where buried gold is um
good reason to watch until the end so I
think that those are all ways to um
power up the hook and to make your the
intro of your video
better show don't just tell
um and give a people a reason to watch
until the end and articulate you know a
structure of kind of what's coming up
and then it doesn't need to be long to
be
lethal I think cut to the chase like
some sometimes you could over intro the
video I think get straight to it and uh
that could be very helpful I hope that
was valuable smash like let's see how
Matthew's doing Matthew hey sorry about
that I think I think we double checked
it's you sound like a whole new it's
beautiful like we just entered into the
studio I'm glad we fixed it it'll make
the conversation a lot crispier for the
audience so um uh really grateful all
right Matt uh break down what your
Channel's all about and how long you've
been doing this um so I've been doing a
lot YouTube over the last two or three
years experimenting with things but just
recently I've kind of niched down over
the last year or so I guess um so I try
to build gaming PCs in different
budgets um whether or just do parts for
those PCS where they can find them for
the best deals for the best prices and
uh it's been close to a year now and
going okay uh but definitely looking to
improve now I'm just curious vid IQ
installed this news feature that says
this Channel's not monetized is your
channel not monetized no actually is my
watch hours that are um lagging behind
you gota be close YouTube short well
YouTube shorts um actually got me a ton
of subscribers but those don't count
towards watch time so um I'm very behind
in the watch time and I'm nowhere close
to the 10 million views or whatever I
need for shorts gotcha so I've kind of
toned down on the YouTube shorts um I'm
actually monetized on on Tik Tok and so
I was reposting both places a lot and
that helped but I'll never reach that 10
million I don't think and so I've tried
to refocus on long form on my YouTube
channel to try to get that 4,000 I'm
over halfway there I'm about, 1500
away beautiful okay well um what is your
biggest question I got a lot of context
here but what would be your articulated
bigest question so um I have this theme
going on with the orangish but the
thumbnails kind of seem simple and the
last couple have not done well so I'm
afraid like I've maybe reused it too
much so I'm looking to tweak it but I
don't want something that looks totally
different like I have the one there with
the PC that's slightly different than
all the other ones I don't know if that
matters and so I guess in an effort to
increase watch time that's what I'm I
don't know I know watch time getting
them to click on it my clickthrough
rates have been lower the last few
videos let me ask you this too um
what uh are you getting affiliate income
at least some from New Egg or somewhere
um very very little that's just started
to get traction over the last month or
so um but it's not very much at all so
I'm working on incorporating that
gotcha okay so couple thoughts number
one I don't
think it's bad for you to break the
orange I love the orange I love your
thumbnails I think they're crispy I
think they're clear
I
think the
argument you would probably make and
others for the Orange is
like that's my brand and I want to be
recognizable and get that click-through
rate because of it I don't think it'll
achieve that I think it's sure it's
Unique and it's Unique to you but
there's plenty of other people that have
the same look I do like it I think your
whole branding it's all fine it's not
bad I don't think my point is it's not
the secret I don't think it's going to
be the thing that helps you win so I
think if you and I like when you break
with it in this one I think that
um that that's not GNA hurt anything
sometimes I might refresh
viewers let's solve for clickthrough
rate I think the mistake people are
making with click-through rate is
they're thinking could I title it better
and could I make a better thumbnail
could I also improve the video and
improve the watch time because that's
also going to reinforce you know let's
let's also just
all rally together and remember what it
is that affects the video's
performance so YouTube is telling us
three things in these little Windows
right they're saying number one views
but views is actually more of a result
than it is actually what's affecting the
performance it's saying click-through
rate which is for six here on today's
video it's saying average view duration
both in which case are average but you
have to imagine they're going to affect
they're going to a lot of different
factors they're going to put these
against other videos on the platform
that these videos are competing with
including your own so
if all things being equal on someone's
homepage a video is more likely to get
someone to not just click but also get
someone to hold their average view
duration um then somebody else's video
would be performed outside of mine we
can know this especially if you haven't
do you have the YouTube studio app on
your phone uh yes I do good reminder to
coffee with canel to re to download your
YouTube studio app um and in your studio
app looking good video is performing at
it as it should
um every once in a while in the YouTube
studio
app when a video is doing really well
it'll give you like sentences of
why and
sometimes what those sentences will say
YouTube telling you is it'll say your
video has x% click-through rate other
videos in your Niche are actually more
like a seven and a half yours is 4.7 but
then that it's going to speak to the cap
of that particular area um your watch
time is it's so it's comparing it to
your own channel it's also comparing it
to others that was a long detour away
from the point that I want to get to for
your Channel which is
this I think
that the reason this th this video only
has 425 views has nothing to do with the
thumbnail I think the thumbnail is
great the title's all right but it's the
topic itself like this PC looks nice but
is it worth it well what PC so unless
this becomes an absolute Banger because
you're trusted and people want to know
what PC it is and it can take liftoff to
get that thousand but think it's much
more a reflection
of and everything you did is good I just
think it quote unquote failed I just
think it was worth worthwhile test and
it didn't work like it didn't create
that much curiosity or clickthrough or
people sticking with it and then vice
versa I think
that is the RTX 5700 XT still good for
gaming for gaming PC in 2023 and still
getting seven views per hour is that a
good thumbnail well yeah it's not bad
but it's that's you know it's good like
it's it's clear it says worth
it it's I see what I'm looking at but
why are people after that well they're
after it because it's answering a
specific question it's it's it's
reviewing a specific product you're
bringing it into a current time frame
and so success leaves Clues based on
topic let me just to oversimplify so
we're on the same page I sometimes even
when we re release a new video a new
video and I'm discouraged by its
performance and I think could I change
the title thumbnail to improve its
performance we just did a coffee with
Ken recently about that yes you can do
that sometimes there's
tweaks
but sometimes no matter how much title
or thumbnail you
change it it can't actually number one
can it actually change the average view
duration probably not unless you set
better expectations with the title and
and there was a dissonance people it
goes higher because you're not even
you're click baiting less there's a
reason for people because what they're
actually clicking on pushes the average
viation up because expectations are set
properly but the punchline is the topic
itself every topic has a particular lid
on it a broad appeal to it how
interested are people on this and no
amount of title tweaking or thumbnail
tweaking could imp improve the
performance of the video which leads me
to the
prescription of where I think one of
your biggest opportunities is and that's
going to be identifying and coming up
with
something you've been proven to do and
that is long form
videos that get six s 11,000 28,000
views you're probably like of course
Sean obviously but like I mean if you
have you've already done it so if you
can start making 2,000 2500 4,000 and
and in my opinion it's G it's gonna
be you already you you can write titles
and and thumbnails they're great it's
going to be topics it's going to be the
next topics and then of course the
Fulfillment of the perfect video recipe
in the video itself but I already know
you have the capability of doing that
because people are you know pleased with
some of these one other quick thing and
we we can unpack and discuss this I do
think there's something about you
pushing it over eight just as an
experiment that I would love to connect
with you in a couple months on like not
fluffing your videos up for no reason
but making promises and titles the topic
that necessitate
a 9 minute video an8 minute 30 second
video of value by the way again assuming
average percentage viewed it's going to
get you to your watch hour sooner and
once you get monetized it will pay more
because over eight you can have multiple
ad spots right
so it's there's there's a few reasons
for doing it I'm not talking about fluff
or wasting people's time I'm talking
about what are the next five to 10 best
videos for you to
make and what's what of those if we
extend our test if you're just joining
copy with canel this would be a good
episode to watch the replay of warning
there was a critical PC crash but I Rose
Like a Phoenix and I'm back um and we
talked with ginger about you know five
to 10 good videos of coming up with our
next best topics and so I think
identifying for you what are five to 10
of the next best videos for you to
make um going a little bit
longer um and scoring videos how easy
would it be for you to make is it is it
a versus video that is already existing
in the parts that you have at home could
it be actually a four-way battle and you
Benchmark four cards against each other
because there's four cards that are
already at your house and people would
find that fascinating enough because as
you go through the things the end the
video ends up being about 10 minutes
long that being true all four of those
can have affiliate links and it it can
get you to your watch time and your your
one video away from hitting in 4,000
hours people say that in our V groups a
couple people in the last week said that
they're like Sean always says you're one
video away one video got me enough hours
like you know that how YouTube Works
makes total sense you get enough views
on something um and it's got a average
percentage viewed or average view
duration is six minutes it's boom you
get 100,000 views or whatever it's like
that's the math all that to say is how
easy would it be for me to make back to
our scoring what are the next five to 10
videos I should make and and do they all
score well for personally easy to make
audience desire Monet amount we could
monetize from Affiliates now and then
getting you monetized um desire of the
audience and then Simplicity of the
concept thumbnail all of the above I
think you're a few videos away from
making some big moves uh what are your I
that was a really long rant forgive me
mat what do you think uh about any of
that or follow-up
questions um yeah so the eight minutes
I've seen a lot of that from your guys
videos and so I've been trying to figure
out different ways to do that with maybe
expanding I don't know if expanding is
the right word but changing or finding
some topics along the lines of what I
already do but I those single graphics
card videos to keep people watching it's
been hard to try to stretch that without
fluffing into the 8 Minute Mark so
that's kind of where I've been stuck
because I think that will help watch
time longer videos and if I ever do get
monetized I know that and it helps with
the multiple ad spots so that's been
brainstorming in my mind and what I've
been kind of thinking about but I guess
I'm also afraid to do that on the
channel because I know I have something
that works somewhat and gets me that
five to I had the one with 28,000 views
going away from that I guess scares me a
little bit with my channel the way it is
currently I would com I would say that
is a I respect I'm grateful you share
that but but I would say that's a
completely unnecessary
fear I my hunch is especially if you're
saying shorts push these up you can even
pull the state up for me I'm curious uh
my hunch is your shorts viewers are not
converting to long form suit different
audiences um that's been our main
experience so if they're not doing that
you're making a lot of assumptions about
your audience like man they're going to
be really upset if I do an eight minute
because they they think about I have a
three minute number one your shorts
viewers don't even see anything two your
long for viewers I doubt they're that
far down the road like man yeah mat you
always did three minutes he did an eight
minute video this guy freaking sold out
man what the heck they're talking to
their friends about it they text their
girlfriend dude I was watching this guy
I I loved his content up until this
point it's all around three to four
minutes dude he released a 10-minute
video can you believe his audacity like
people are talking behind your back back
they start like Discord forums about you
there's like the level of offense like
it gets picked up by Newsweek Time
Magazine how
Matthew did an eight minute
video cancel you're being cancelled on
all the platforms the
attire you think that's what gonna
happen uh no but I needed someone like
you to tell me that I guess to make
myself feel
better I don't think that's what's going
to happen if you go to analytics if you
go to content and you go to all there's
viewers across formats you know one of
the big the interesting things is that
this is just our numbers you can tell me
yours shorts only 46% basically five out
of 10 people on our think media
viewership in 28 days only watch shorts
and then only one out of 10 people watch
both and then the
other five out of 10 that's 11 people
but that's the I'm 46 8% 46
um so half only watch videos and not
shorts half only watch shorts and not
video and the overlap is only
10% so that that's just some really
important data to know and I like I I'm
glad you're focusing on long form I
think you should focus on long form I
think that long
form traditional YouTube videos are your
best path to
monetization I think that I'm not trying
to talk anybody watching this out of
doing shorts I think it could be a part
of your overall equation but if I'm you
I'm asking what's the shortest path to
revenue the shortest path to going
fulltime and to me that's on making some
strategic videos that are long form I
think I think that
um success leaves Clues and I think that
some of these
videos why is this 13 minutes this was
the top of my video that popped in my
mind best gpus you can buy right now
with the month update or the day update
could you make that video is there any
reason you could or
couldn't no I don't reckon I have any
reason I couldn't necessarily I some of
the newer stuff that they do obviously
I'm not at the point where I can do that
kind of stuff but I could do it with I
can do it with the budget side of things
which I deal with most of the time have
you made a best of budget video yet I
have not so to me that is that's where
it's like if all things being equal that
rises such to the top back to our
scoring system okay here's 10 good ideas
nine of those I don't have the cards for
it as a side quest I might ask how could
I get my hands on them even if I borrow
them even you know like could you get a
contact could it be a computer store
there's this channel um that I find very
entertaining called camera conspiracies
and some of the not only is it like
camera reviews but it's almost like he's
a comedian as
well and he is in Canada and he
partnered up with a local camera shop
and his Channel's grown to a decent size
and whatnot but he gets his hands on a
lot of a lot of lender units so that's
the side quest question whereas we in
the coffee with canel think media
Community here always want to be asking
it's not like I can't do it it's how
could I do it it's like I don't have the
money I don't have the time where could
I find the money where could I find the
time I don't have the connections I
don't have the relationships where could
I find the relationships where could I
find the connections but that's still
going to be
the answers to those questions means
it's going to be harder to make that
those videos with things you don't have
than the ones you do so you answered you
just narrowed it down what I could do is
maybe these older cards or these cards
under $500 or these cards under
,000 and then when you hone in like a
laser on that video idea that you're
capable of making you have experience
with the cards you already have the
cards you can do the affiliate links you
can make the great title you already
know you're good at all the skill sets
boom
now it's a win-win win win win because
you might get 41,000 views on a 13
minute video that kicks you over to
monetization that brings new people to
your world and then it's money you don't
have right now with that mindset of
aggressive reinvesting it's my preferred
method of course you take a pace you're
comfortable with is
like you just want to once you start a
fire you want to keep adding fuel to the
fire wisely iers ifying your income but
what I mean is like money starts coming
in I know gpus could be so expensive
like you could spend your whole
eventually two three grand a month on ad
revenue on one GPU that's why I'd be
maybe more interested in like is there
is there rental opportunity but it's
like reinvesting is like renting paying
shipping costs getting a connection
buying a plane ticket to go to an event
to get education to make a connection to
network with somebody because if you
open up that you know bus Business
Development just reinvest investing in
the business of getting the workflow of
the tools and gear for your vision the
way that looked for me I think media of
course early on it was buying quite a
few cameras buying different lenses I
will I will say this though we would
hone in at think
media in fact we still do it to this day
every once in a while because I'll
approve expenditures Nolan will be like
Kyle will be like can we get a
A7 R4 to do a video and I'm like no and
here's why if it's like a $4,000 body so
I'm like number one it's not relevant
for most people sure a lot of like
higher end photographers and craters but
the $4,000 what are you talking about
like that's and then I'm like number two
how many videos are we actually G to
make number three where then the flip
side we already have a zve E10 here that
Omar's making videos with and and Nolan
will be like well I could make more
videos with the zve E10 but I don't have
one and I'll be like dude it's a $800
camera of course course it's still
that's money cost us money but it's like
ship him the zv E10 it's a camera that
everybody loves it's already proven or
tested it's at the right price point in
the market it's kind of a side quest too
but just this idea of the reinvesting
and we're getting ahead of ourselves in
a way but as money's coming in strategic
reinvestment and everybody watching this
thinking about that sometimes we do dumb
stuff like I'm going to get a an 80 to
300 landscape you know Wildlife lens for
six grand because I could make one video
you're like but then if you're like I'm
going to buy a 50 and a couple like this
is our world you know the it's it's it's
Justified
investments in things that you also know
would monetize and that would map
towards and and to that point let me
simplify the takeaway playing in the
word budget playing around the world of
cheapest playing around the the word of
afford
that's always going to be a larger
market of course than the premium that's
kind of what I'm suggesting and so it's
a win-win win because it's more
affordable for you to buy the very best
newest budget card because you know you
can turn that into five to 10 videos
you're making a calculated risk and
you're thinking about the longtail of
the ROI of the Affiliates related to
that and the ad revenue and everything
that comes with that knowing that that's
also the most relatable card to the
largest group of people AKA YouTube
brought appeal that would be where that
strategy comes from and side quest do
that make
sense yeah absolutely and so that's kind
of what I keep in mind I told you
earlier I made a I make a little bit off
Tik Tock and I try to reinvest all of
that and take those same things but now
I'm starting to try to work backwards
focus on the YouTube stuff and just take
YouTube and move it over to Tik Tok
because I know that's where that's where
the revenues best is in the world of
YouTube um and I do take most of these
on the side and either through Facebook
Marketplace or whatever once I have
enough parts for a whole PC I do sell
them secondhand on and get some of that
money back and have more money to
reinvest so I have been doing that a
little I've been doing that a little bit
and so it's been a slow process to
acquire a lot of stuff um but I'm
working with that now and so I'm just
trying to hone in the focus of how can I
make more videos with what I have and
make them longer and find what my
audience wants so so but talking to you
helps me a lot actually uh I've thought
of a lot of stuff while we've been
sitting here talking of how we might can
do that so it affirms that I'm on the
right track yeah you're doing you have a
lot of good things going and your skills
are really sharp I mean you know titles
thumbnails you know watching a clip 3di
here in 2023 let's find out it was
released at the end of 2020 and it great
energy Fe eight8 gigs of vram now this
version we're testing today actually
came out a little later than that and it
has the gddr 6X version of the vram
we're gonna put it to the T Cuts all the
stuff so so I hope you I want you to
feel encouraged you you've you've built
a lot of
momentum sharpen your skills there's a
lot of good things waiting for you on
the other side of a lot of strategic
execution really grateful for you Matt
um any final questions as we land the
plane here and then coffee with C smash
like I'm going to hit you your text
questions that are coming in right after
this go ahead Matt no uh this
encouragement has been awesome so I
really appreciate it y'all have answered
the biggest questions that I had and I'm
excited to go get to work awesome
appreciate you Matthew thanks for coming
on all right coffee with Kel smash like
we are one hour and 15 minutes into our
episode today let me know if you're just
jumping on we've had two conversations
one with a yarn channel one with a PC
Building GPU Channel Channel and a lot
of uh takeaways there Hi teacher Kelly
good to see you um and I saw Tech hawk
share this my heart sunk the zve E10 in
a good way on Prime day was $480 with
the kit lens that is insanity I saw
Amazon do another Prime day and it
frankly I was exhausted I was like what
are how many prime days what do what it
was like Prime day two days ago or
whatever right or yesterday something
but talk about the ultimate steel which
does none of us any good at this moment
because they're already sold out but
that's an insane price zve E10 I want to
say is our bestselling
camera um and when I say our bestselling
as an affiliate uh it is the number one
most purchased camera for people
clicking our links that would be from
our videos but I would argue it's not
even just from our videos we have the
opportunity here at think media to
observe almost like what You' call Big
Data like just certain Trends with our
own internal data um in
fact um I will tell you this just
because I'm fascinated and it's fun
doing things Niche stuff that coffee Cel
gets to see that nobody else does when
you're watching it 1 hour and 17 minutes
in so here's our affiliate links for
September 1st through the 30th here's
our top 10 most sold products
number one is the Sony ZB E10 we did 36
units and our commission was
$1,127 on there the sigma 16 those two
things together is kind of like the bomb
combo too right that's 49 of those the
cinema line here by the way speaking of
high-end the cinema line fx30 super 35
this would be Kyle being like C but
notice talk about like high ticket too
so this is a $2,100 camera not super
high ticket but five units got us 439
bucks then our KN were super heavy duty
light
standand pretty sick um DJI mics the q2u
such a great mic 134 units there's some
lessons here too you know if something's
cheaper you got to do more units if
something's more expensive you got to do
less math the more you know um but it
it's it's it's you know something to
think about strategically um and we got
DJI mik the mount dog softbox lights
aperture
Lantern and then Sony zv E10 is still on
the top 10 list just the body with no
lens also made it on there so oh no no
no forgive me the Sony zv E1 that is a
different camera so the E10 is number
one Sony
[Music]
zv1 also made it on there newer camera
also much more expensive uh fullframe
camera the
zb1 the more you know that was a little
insight that we got to do
together um hanging out Samuel's sipping
on some coffee deal Billy I appreciate
you glad you're getting value today I
need money I feel you I mean that's it
is true and especially to buy cameras
and things
um and uh you're right I think is
talking about Matthew and he said this
dude is GNA pop so
good I don't know what that was
referencing to but I agree I think
Matt's going to blow up and I think
Ginger is too all right let's answer
your questions this is the coffee with
Kenall show if you're just joining my
name is Sean Kel rhymes with YouTube
channel uh we bring on guests we kind of
do Channel reviews we talk through
things um and then we also answer your
questions I got about eight questions in
in a few minutes to answer some of those
if you have any more questions we'll get
to those in just a second
uh right after this quick break the
brand new and updated version of YouTube
Secrets second edition is out now learn
the strategies of today's top video
influencers in this stepbystep YouTube
Playbook get your paperback Kindle or
audiobook today at yts.com or by
clicking the link in the show notes or
the
description
yts.com have you read the second edition
of YouTube Secrets at yts.com you can
get the second edition brand new and
updated 90 new pages some deleted
chapters and so uh highly recommend that
uh also available on Audible if you're a
listening type and a great way to
reinforce just YouTube best practices
and all those kind of things probably
one of you know because very affordable
books are not that expensive
books as a side note not just because
it's my book look at my shelf behind
here I'll go on my stories I'll post
other books books books are one of my
favorite things but here's why the fact
you can get 20 years of somebody's life
for
$20 the fact you can get 10 years of
someone's experience wisdom and mistakes
for $10 the fact you can get a couple
hours of someone's wisdom
refined written down and then read into
a high quality mic in an audio book and
listen to that while you're walking your
dog doing your chores doing your
responsibilities pushing your kids in a
stroller on a weekend for one audible
credit or seven bucks there's one of the
biggest most you know highly leveraged
things you could ever invest in if you
don't buy my book please buy books if
you don't read books please start
reading books and if you're not a big
reader listen because lifelong leaders
are lifelong Learners and I without a
doubt I think the amount of strategy
and helping like becoming a a strategist
and developing how you
think media de developing your thinking
your
strategy it might sometimes feel like
not just like a YouTube book reading
books on marketing reading books on
copywriting reading books on
communication reading books on speaking
listening to books on all the
above can so enhance your YouTube
channel I know they have mine so um
yts.com if you want to check that out
but let me know and let me know what
books are you reading any book
recommendations that you have uh let me
know
and
uh let's answer your
questions thoughts on building a channel
around news and current events you just
mentioned before but curious if there's
anything new I think it's
um one it's a solid strategy two one of
the ways to test a strategy is to go see
if there's anybody else doing it you
will find many examples of people doing
it successfully
three there's a famous verse in the Book
of Luke of Jesus is giving some advice
and he's telling people he says doesn't
a builder before building a tower count
the cost of building that Tower to see
if he has enough time and resources to
finish it because if he doesn't and he
only gets halfway through then people
are going to laugh at him and mock him
that's essentially what the parable says
and then he says doesn't a military
General
assess the enemy's forces and his own
forces before going to battle so that he
doesn't just go into battle and get
slaughtered of course he does and so his
whole point is count the cost and in
that Bible verse he's talking about
count the cost of being a disciple of
following Christ but of course there's
so much wisdom the Bible is the best
greatest success book ever written uh
the greatest leadership book ever
written the greatest Business book ever
written so you could take something like
that to say okay not only could I win
this battle but also do I have the time
and energy and is that what I want to
build as far as a channel I love it
um I'm for it but it's not my favorite
and V video ranking Academy students
know that as we're teaching our Sr
system our favorite type of content is
Evergreen content by the way I think CH
content can coexist on a channel meaning
you can Embrace Trend surfing and
influence surfing the kind of Channel
you're talking about while also EMB ring
Evergreen
topics um and in doing
so so long as the value proposition of
the
channel serves the subscribers in both
cases that is the most lethal type of
channel for example I will do breaking
YouTube news on think media and I will
do a ranked video about YouTube
strategy that's how I think you should
think about your channel so you asked my
advice uh as you were here
those are I'm giving you more questions
than answers you need to architect your
future you need to architect the channel
you want to build as much as possible
you want to look ahead two three four
five years let's assume this is going to
be a smashing success we literally did
coaching on a coffee with can episode
and as a reminder you can always go back
into think media
podcast they could probably be labeled
better is our playlist game strong I'm
not sure if our coffee with canel
episodes the one way you could do it is
you go to the live tab here and they're
not really notably super different but
in one of the last two episodes I
coached a news a guy that's doing Pure
News full-time money coming in but you
know what he said oh dude I'm so busy
and crazy right now I like am uh so
let's see here's coffee with canel one
of the best ways to earn money from home
and build a life and a business on your
own terms is creating
um I don't think this playlist is
updated but we'll get it
updated of all of our coffee with kenel
episodes we kind of have a unique way of
doing things here where we don't dis we
don't say that the show is coffee with
canel in the title you maybe notice that
it's because my opinion it doesn't have
any value whole separate conversation uh
but uh but one of the ways we can
organize that and we will be doing that
is is making sure that we get it in the
playlist as well as the hashtags that we
add to the episode so #think media
podcast or rather hasag coffee withan
hasag Sean canel um and
[Music]
so a student of
ours has a current events and News
Channel and maybe that's what you
want because this is a good goal to have
he's got money coming in he's got he's
doing it fulltime he's got more money
than he thought would be coming in but
he doesn't know how to get out of the
hamster wheel now and so we talked a
little bit about team a little bit about
systems a little bit about shifting some
of the content to Evergreen that's my
only warning for you different channels
different things but in the Creator
economy it's smart to architect think
ahead and uh those are all some
considerations David says shorts or not
shorts I do both at the moment even live
streams the business model would be to
convert to courses Microsoft Excel NS
cheers I mean David I got you know 30
other questions for
you
um are you by
yourself do you have too much
money are you you're like I don't even
know where to put this money I got cash
under my mattress I got like my banker
is like we we can't even hold it
all and I'm joking but I'm serious what
what are your problems do you have
enough time do you have too much time do
you have too much money no not enough
time not enough money because like for
example we do shorts but I do a video
podcast and I've used money to hire
somebody to cut shorts out of it and
then a social media manager schedules
those
shorts and I do a lot of them but notice
how I do them now I also make original
shorts from my phone I get
inspired I'd say two a month I do two
crafted shorts built
out and cap cut two to four a month by
myself and we're all in I'm number one
incredibly blessed I'm obviously a
full-time YouTuber but the better
accurate I'm actually a fulltime CEO
founder that also has got a lot of other
things that I'm juggling now because of
the nature of what comes with that so
all of us you know you might easy for
you to say Sean you got other people
well nothing's easy for anything anybody
to say we all have different things
going on like we're in different seasons
of maybe how much money we have but how
much time we have and then somebody
might I could go look at the single
person that's watching this right now be
like what the heck are you doing bro
you're freaking single you're not even
dating anybody you work 32 hours a week
at your job you have no excuse to not be
blowing it up on YouTube you got so many
hours that could be optimized in your
schedule there's 13 moms watching this
right now that want to punch you in the
face because they figured out how to do
YouTube even though they've got two
diapers to change lunch to pack in bags
dinner to cook a husband they're trying
to keep happy and he's super grumpy so
we all have different things we're going
through so should you do shorts or
should you not do shorts of you
shouldn't if you can't you should if you
could uh I think if you want to sell
courses is you should optimize content
to sell courses if you do free Excel
tutorials and you want to make AdSense
those monies you know those videos make
big money there's so many Excel
tutorials that have one two three four
five million views and they're like an
hour long so that's a good Niche to
optimize towards live streams too if
they're Evergreen live streams they have
high replay value so it's a cool
question I I mainly just ranted David
related to your question should you do
shorts or not shorts yes should you do
live streams if they're good if they
have replay value I think and should
eventually you have people you know
should you get people into your course
sure all the above could do that shorts
are hard if you're going if you're
trying to go direct because links are no
longer clickable now shorts have the
related video thing we've been testing
it doesn't work that good and what I
mean by that is um you can study the
watch
time of your traffic
sources and here's what we've learned
y'all did you know that you can connect
a related video to shorts so there's a
link there's a clickable video on the
short right underneath the title
clickable link here's the
problem in one of our viral shorts we
link to an 18-minute video but the watch
time is 45 seconds what does that tell
us when the traffic Source comes from
shorts to a long form video the
attention isn't Shifting the mindset of
the person moving to the next thing is
still in like a less than 60-second
mindset that's verifiable what at least
in our somewhat of a limited test but
that's data driven
Insight are we mad about that no are we
stopping doing it
no the reason you might stop is because
you might
say well is YouTube actually is it GNA
hurt that video that some of the traffic
is actually much less average view
duration takeaways shorts viewers
converting to Long viewers is very tough
not your fault meaning it's just they're
in the mode of like scrolling scrolling
that's the kind of content they want to
watch they're not like oh I'm like
getting all these dopam it's you think
about it's
biology is it biology is it
neurology dopamine though I'm actually
consuming a lot of shorts these days and
when I'm usually consuming shorts all I
ever do on the long form is I add to
watch later I'm too I'm too much in an
addiction cycle give me more you know 10
seconds 20 seconds 30 seconds oh cool
that person was on that podcast add to
watch later dopamine dopamine dopamine I
can't get out of that cycle is your
maybe your willpower is better than mine
I'm just my phone is taking control of
my whole life and mind and everything
so I I think it's going to be hard to
make some of those bridges from short
form to long form just because the mode
the person's in mind you one person that
might help everybody watching this on
your own content to just think about
like the people you serve I am adding
videos to watch later and then I am
putting my phone down getting my airpods
in strapping up my son John and my son
sha in our double Tulie stroller heading
out for a walk that I do basically every
morning and every night after dinner
walking around the neighborhood for 30
minutes and going to my watch later
playlist and listening to a video
podcast because I I don't walk down the
street and just the shorts two different
environments interesting rant that we're
in there um detour we're taking lots of
side
quests um smash like and uh and I don't
even know if we're getting value here
but I didn't know David I had no idea
too funny uh but David I'll tell you
what you don't have is any excuses
because if you're in a season and David
I don't know if you replied with like
how much time you have because also if
you got a 50-hour week job it's a whole
different situation than if you're
already doing this
full-time um and uh we'll keep it moving
I appreciate you David thanks so much
for the question coffee with canel we
have like eight more questions we'll go
through a couple more here and uh we're
gonna get to those really soon I just
want to sip a little bit more water and
so I'll be right back in one sec are you
ready to start or grow your YouTube
channel do you feel stuck and need help
connecting the dotts join this free web
class where you'll learn the
step-by-step playbook for YouTube
success we've helped thousands of
purpose-driven entrepreneurs just like
you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at think masterclass.com
welcome back to the coffee with canel
show my name is Sean canel rhymes with
YouTube channel and I am answering your
questions all about
YouTube all right I already answered
this one
what about email
lists lecta on videos you know what's a
big Trend right now is
newsletters I don't know if you've seen
it yet but people are building their
newsletters with YouTube videos it's a
great idea by the way what we just did
what I just did was also that is
building my email list because think
masterclass.com is an optin so it is the
the free gift is a deep dive hourong
training and it's also just maybe a
matter of what you promote Because by
the way when you sign up for think
masterclass.com you get instant access
to an OnDemand hourlong YouTube
training but a side benefit that we
don't even really promote is we have a
really great newsletter and you're kind
of just you instantly get that we have a
Weekly Newsletter you know it's hard
enough to keep up with the podcast we
put out the main Channel stuff the other
stuff we have going on so it's people
one of people's favorite things is being
signed up for our newsletter just
because even checking into the YouTube
app sometimes trying to protect your
focus you don't want to get sucked into
a dopamine cycle you know of short form
content the newsletter right into your
inbox and so you can sign up for
something like think masterclass.com and
there's a link to that in the
description so there you go there is I
just gave a call to action to our email
list and I do think that is smart if
it's part of kind of your business or
how you serve people Bruno and all of
the
above George is there if there are two
or three different seasons of the same
Niche do you think it's better to have
several YouTube channels or having all
one with the sessions inside sessions
well I'm gonna keep it moving just
because I don't maybe know exactly okay
here we go in my case it's about pigeons
and there are homing pigeons other kinds
of pigeons and I'm talking about on
sever several channels if it's all
pigeons to me I feel like only you know
like you would know if
if like people who want homing pigeon
content hate people that like other
kinds of pigeons and they're
[Music]
like I subscribed for homing pigeon
content but now he's covering other
stuff I am out of here I am cancelling
him because I don't understand the niche
so if that's true then maybe it's
multiple channels but in the case
of of you thinking there's different
niches of pigeons I think we might be on
a different page as far as what a niche
is a niche of course I think pigeons is
a niche within a niche within a niche
because you could have like you know
birds or you could have animals so think
about like Animal Planet people like
Animal Planet and they watch shows on
Apple TV in these different places and
discovery of all kinds of animals it's a
good Niche but it's not even a specific
animal now on the channel there might be
like the Turtles episode and like like
people then can decide if they want to
watch that or not so if your entire
YouTube channel is about
pigeons sometimes I think you can Niche
too far and then birds and then what is
the promise though is it like how to
raise them how to feed them how to
whatever is it entertainment is it
education um I think there's definitely
some assessment I and and then let me
give macro advice because you then ask
should I have two to three should I have
several YouTube channels here's what I
don't recommend for 99 % of people
watching this you should not have
several YouTube channels one of the
biggest mistakes you can make in the
Creator economy is to have several
YouTube channels why Sean because if you
try and Chase two to three rabbits
you'll end up catching none of them
especially true with pigeons if you try
and Chase five pigeons at once you'll
catch none of them it's hard enough to
catch one pigeon almost impossible dang
birds can fly you know what I mean plus
they're dirty why do you even want to
catch them okay forgive me
so while
many people ask this question Sean I'm
doing this and I'm doing this and I'm
doing
this should those be on three
channels my answer oftentimes is well by
the sounds of it those things are so
different
yes but I'm you're asking the wrong
question in my opinion the better
question is what one thing what one
YouTube channel what one
business should I focus on right
now that has the highest
likelihood of helping me reach my
ultimate personal
financial and career
goals so even though I might have helped
you clarify oh yeah those are three
different niches so you should divide up
the content into three different buckets
we're at the wrong place in the
conversation unless of course your goal
is not to unless you don't have any
career goals financial goals and your
goal is to just create content and
organize it well if your goal is to
create content and organize it well then
you really want to put this over here
and put this over here and put this over
here I'm trying to help you step back
and say where is it you want this to go
what's the brand what's the vision
what's the mission what's the what's the
mission what's the
business and which vehicle
AKA which one YouTube channel has the
highest likelihood of getting you there
then it would be your discipline to not
do the other channels but to focus
follow one course until successful it's
worth writing down Focus f o c s follow
one course until successful the acronym
to get
hyperfocused and avoid doing multiple
channels regardless if that's the best
way to segment the content I'm asking
all of us how could you actually do
less not
more it is of my opinion with
many scars to show over my last 20 years
doing video and 16 years doing
YouTube that the majority of
creators are slowing
down their arrival time at their
destination because of too much busyness
too much distraction and too much wasted
time you're going to get there faster by
doing less it's a hard less to get clear
on but you got to get clear on your
goals clear on the best videos clear on
your strategy clear on your Niche clear
on your marketing clear on the whole
thing clear on the market clear on
Market Research clear on the niche clear
on everything to come up with the best
strategy for moving
forward that's my advice thanks so much
for the question George brother Sean
blessings what kind of wireless
microphone should I get DJI or
Road both are really good we debated
this today at think media you can't go
wrong with either of them Michael
um not too far yet on my YouTube channel
but looking to improve affiliate links
for finance credit card Channel other
than books or wallets what would be good
to refer viewers
to so
Michael it it doesn't
matter if you're not too far on the
YouTube channel and you're not getting
the views my
argument is your biggest problem is the
views not more affiliate
strategies so if you're already approved
for credit card
Affiliates it's such a lucrative
opportunity Dave Ramsey doesn't like you
but it's a lucrative
opportunity
um and books on Personal Finance amazing
I don't know what you mean by wallets
like Ridge wallets or like digital
wallets also
great but my heartfelt advice for you is
one great video that's getting views
getting clicked on getting shared and
that's structured in such a way as to
add legitimate value build legitimate
trust add real content it's not a cash
grab it's not a money grab it's not an
affiliate grab I'm not saying you're
doing that
I'm just
saying the video accomplishes a lot of
things because you sat down and you
intentionally wo those things into the
video really good value hours of
research really helpful then all of the
above would be help but all of the above
affiliate opportunities would be good
it's also more what do you care about
what's going to serve people the most
but Michael what the number one problem
to solve I think would be the growth in
the views because views is also is going
to be the key to making anything work
monetization work obviously hitting a
th000 subscribers 4,000 hours of watch
time but it's the key to making
Affiliates work too because although you
can start making Affiliates even if
you're not monetized you're only going
to make any kind of Revenue at
scale by getting enough views and I have
one disclaimer for that
except the one the one the one
disclaimer like we had a student in
video ranking Academy in our private
Facebook group Trevor he
posted his vid IQ badge you know your
badge tells you when you reach 10,000
subscribers when it when you reach you
know 25,000 subscribers you get a little
badge and people share it on social
people share them in our groups all the
time Trevor shared his and the Milestone
it's your Milestone badge the
Milestone was 1,5 00 views on the
channel
total
now if you're been on YouTube for very
long 1,500 views is not very many
views right I'm not trying to belittle
the Milestone because you don't even
know where this story is
going if you've been on YouTube very
long in the last two years you can kind
of like put out a short that's not very
G good and get 1,500 views if all you
want is the vanity metric of like I got
a thousand views not
subscribers in the lifetime of your
channel that's not a that's many many
people probably wouldn't celebrate that
Milestone they'd celebrate a thousand
Subs but like
1,500
views across all videos on the channel
so Trevor does this post puts up the
milestone done here's what the caption
says though
hey super
excited because I've done
$2,000 so far in affiliate commissions
from my videos I'm only halfway through
the V training but I'm pretty happy with
the results so
far so now let's add this up Trevor
across all of his videos had only gotten
1,500
views Ginger earlier on her yarn channel
was getting I think 100,000 views a
month or something like that right
whatever it was Trevor only had 1,500
views total in the LIF in the lifespan
of his of his channel but he had already
collected
$2,000 how sean I'm glad you
asked a really good question when you
were saying is the the the the the big
secret
the the big answer to how is that
possible is the size of the affiliate
opportunity if you can earn 50% on an
,000 sale that means you would earn $500
if you only made one
sale if your video got a hundred
views and one person person
purchased an $1,000 product and the
commission percentage was
50% then you just
earned $500 off of a hundred
views so the question now
becomes what affiliate opportunities out
there
exist with those numbers and those terms
what video topics video Search
terms are
exist that could be connected and lead
to affiliate opportunities of that size
and number
three
and addressing your objection but Sean
like that's doesn't exist oh it does
exist this is what the small percentage
of elite YouTube strategists
understand what
clientele
or audience is looking for answers of
that kind because while it might sound
shocking you be like well who's out here
spending a thousand bucks who's out here
spending the higher ticket people all
the time every all the time like with
all due respect just because you don't
have money does not mean that other
people don't have money there's a big
opportunity if you Embrace this line of
thinking there's not a lack of money in
the economy there's not a lack of money
that's available for you there's not a
lack of
money especially if if you're listening
to the news you're probably listening to
the wrong thing look at the trillions of
dollars that are being spent and wasted
every day look at the way here in the US
the government's spending money look at
the grow gross domestic product look at
percentages even if so you can really be
fixated on maybe how strong your
struggle is and it's very legitimate and
you might be fixated on how significant
the struggle is of those around you but
you have to understand that there's a
whole another reality that if you get in
front of the Right audience with the
right product with the right solution
and the right
answer then
there's massive Financial
opportunity it'd be the difference
between doing dollar makeup reviews and
luxury watch reviews on YouTube luxury
watches it's a $10 purches purchase
versus $10,000 purchase and here's my
question do people buy luxury watches
well yes they do well Sean but how am I
going to get my hands on luxury watches
well land the plane here because I
understand it opens up a lot of
questions and we don't have time to
unpack you know all these other nuances
but that's another way to to I think
think about things that's kind of fun
because you're
saying that would be the solution I was
like number one get your views up so it
could be more credit cards or more books
or more
wallets or
Andor what opportunities are there that
could be much more lucrative so you
could do a smaller volume with higher
percentage or higher priced products and
of course I got to keep it moving but we
talk about that kind of stuff inside of
our program and other places um that
becomes the big opportunity that's where
we get excited about a thousand true
fans my friend shellene Johnson said
it's like 500 true fans I'm convinced if
you could build a community the right
Community interested in the right
particular thing with the right
particular pain Point all right Myra
Kate smash like we're Landing the plane
it's it's one hour and 50 minutes in
we're smashing like okay Myra uh my
target audience is Christian women
coaches how do I attract more of my
target audience on videos my analytics
say I have 70% men as
viewers so I think
Myra's think she's gonna be on coffee
with canel in the future because I saw
this I don't remember where I saw this
but let's actually check out her Channel
this is a really good question for
anybody who's wondering what audience
they're
attracting
so one way you
could make sure you attract
female Christian
coaches is by
saying signature course versus mini
course what
female coaches need to know how to
create your course outline in 30 minutes
or less as a
woman what to do if you feel stuck in
creating your
course as a female sell your course now
now you might be saying Sean is that
what you're recommending no I I would I
don't recommend that I don't think you
should do that I'm just saying that's
one of the
ways to narrow your audience is to
narrow your Audience by
saying by calling out your audience now
that is a good strategy it's one
headline copyrighting strategy what
every real estate agent needs to know
about creative Finance what every
Christian content creator needs to know
about what the Bible says about Pride
and ambition what every so there's
certain videos that are are a great
strategy to make but what I want to
Simply do is just answer one of the
reasons why you probably have 70% men is
because you know they did a study they
did a study of people watching content
and they discovered this they discovered
that when it comes to be people watching
content
online that
men
prefer to watch women
online and here's what else they
discovered women prefer to watch women
online sorry guys so the conclusion of
the study was
that like Beyonce
said we who runs the world girls who
runs the world girls okay relax um I'm
kind of half joking that was a real
study we could look it up so so what I
think can happen is whether it's someone
seeing you in the thumbnail they're
looking about whether it's a Christian
entrepreneur like whatever and it's you
just providing good
information I think you've done an
incredible job with your branding by
saying helping Christian women coaches
multiplied their income and impact by
turning their god-given gifts and
expertise into online courses
great but now you just have to embrace I
don't even think there's an answer to
this I think what you do is you just
embrace that you create the content
that's going to serve your target
audience you articulate and clarify your
brand which you've done
you know that that's Pro that's who's
going to be your customers or that's the
only customers you AC accept so it
doesn't even matter if men apply they
just won't get accepted because you've
clarified your brand great but as you
put out YouTube content into the world I
think you just Embrace and accept the
70% man that's my answer and actually
I'd open this up to anybody else here
like you got 70% men as viewers like
they like your content and at scale it's
more ad Revenue it's more stuff and then
it might also open
though if something like that happens
this these are the UN these are like the
cool moments that might happen in a
business that could open
up ideas that you never had at the
beginning you go wow look at this weird
thing happening I wouldn't have thought
this would happen but now there's all
these men you have a certain Market
segment that now you're trying to serve
so for example we recently did a
Christian content creator class because
I recognized that as a Jesus follower
myself as a Bible
nerd there is people that were
resonating with that we have an upcoming
real estate one so yes the V7 seven RS
works for every Niche and every kind of
person however the way you apply it it's
a little bit different in different
contexts you also I don't think as a
real estate agent you need to be focused
on doing like affiliate marketing videos
about books because your affiliate
should be the 3% commission you get on
that $500,000 house so it's like let's
figure out how to do that instead so
there's can be specialized stuff so my
thought is maybe Myra when you see
something like that you start thinking
about bringing on a guest and you Jo you
do a joint venture relationship with a
guy because and you see if there's some
way that the 70% of men watching it
doesn't mean you like this is bizdev
thinking you don't have to start a new
business what business can you partner
with who could you who could you and and
you don't rush into something like that
and by partner I don't mean you have to
become business partners it just means
there's that's what we do here at think
media we have people that we're good at
making online courses but like right
now we are um our friend Marissa
mergatroid if y'all haven't seen the
podcast and you want to start an online
course like or or package what you know
into an online course like she is a
legend this episode the new way to
create online courses and the new way is
creating experience products we're
learning from Marisa right now she she
has a free guide too on the most
profitable niches bestc cours
toopics.com
so we don't currently I have a YouTube
course so you can join video ra Academy
and learn all things YouTube rank videos
on YouTube suggested on YouTube let's do
YouTube I don't have a course about how
to make an online course Marissa does so
that's why we will send you to do we're
an affiliate for her will like let you
know about what she's doing you know how
much energy and how difficult it is to
create to do one thing well that's why I
put my heart and soul and our team puts
our heart and soul into video ranking
Academy and V Elite you know how hard it
is to make and I by the way we used to
have this thing called Inner Circle and
I realized how hard that was I started
chasing three pigeons now I I got rid of
them because I don't want no scrubs a
scrub is a guy who can't get no love I
don't want no pigeons
okay relax uh video ranking Academy
workbook what am I saying I got way off
on that last
one I I'm I'm I want to make this course
better focus on this course I want to go
deeper on this and and partner with
others so anyways I think that's an
interesting thing for you is what
if
you thought about how you could serve
those men without you being like I got
to coach men now not necessarily there
could be other ways um and and just
continue and then on the flip side like
don't even worry about it because at the
end of the day YouTube is probably if
you're doing it right it's going to be a
pretty big funnel you have some viral
videos if you have a viral video half
the people in the comments are like
you're dumb you're stupid you're ugly
that's actually a good sign it means
your video went viral because obviously
it's not the people that like I know
we're insecure about that but it's like
if you start getting millions of views
you know fortnite 42 is going to be like
why is your hair gray at the bottom of
your beard and your side I'm like thanks
bro you know some like Zoomer is just
critiquing me as I turned 40 this year
that just is distribution you're being
distributed broadly on the internet that
person's probably not going to make it
all the way down to like being a part of
deeply listening to the podcast or
joining one of our
programs and so it's so great you got
70% of men cool the the the the the
greater crowd is following you that's
amazing but do you have enough customers
do you have enough are you achieving
your business results and if you're
doing both you've got the broad appeal
up here and it's funneling down to the
customers you want to serve then you're
already winning and I wouldn't worry
about
it what is Nolan's basketball Channel
um basketball
Club
um any uh let's see I get so much
Millennial hate on my channel I feel it
I love it hey thick skin and a soft
heart
appreciate you uh the hater comments
we're out here yeah bestc course
toopics.com if you're thinking about
creating an online course bestc couret
toopics.com is such Marica is really
smart and such an expert in this whole
world of creating online courses and
getting your course right is such an
important um key and so uh yeah
sparkling life C coach has taken her
course yeah she is amazing so Marissa
mergatroid uh she's doing um really
great things out
here um okay you know what friends we've
covered a lot we've
wrapped I don't want no scrubs and I
don't want no no pigeons we've had
guests we've
had whole streams crash blue screen of
death and yet we're still here two hours
into it dang it I didn't turn the stream
off before two hours wouldn't have
probably made a difference
but I like it when it's a little bit
shorter um
and uh yeah that's a good point I don't
know no the quote was my favorite quote
was this this uh I don't know what age
they were but this person goes why does
sea have the face of a boy but the hair
of an old
man that's like thanks for the
encouragement dog I appreciate it you
know thanks for just being out here for
me sending me love could have said great
video could have said great tips could
have said you're helpful could have said
I appreciate you I appreciate the
question too though why do I have the
face of a boy you want to know my
skincare routine sometimes people ask
meanwhile all right this is what you get
on the after the
[Laughter]
uh Nick appreciate you uh that's cold it
was it was pretty cold and but I think
it was innocent too I think there was
like a legitimate like I confused this
individual they just like what
is why why is sea so young and so old at
the same time that's that's a uh rudest
way to say you have nice skin I
appreciate it uh thank you hey just out
here you're helping my insecurities I
really I'm grateful for it thank you so
much all right listen um uh this is
coffee with Kel we're Landing the plane
we'll be back if you haven't subscribed
subscribe if you haven't
subscribed like if you haven't liked the
video remember new thick media podcast
every Tuesday and Thursday so if you're
on this channel and notifications are on
you're locked you're loaded this is the
place where it's all happening and going
down of course if you're also a
connoisseur
of the iner experience we're on Spotify
Google Apple with the think media
podcast coffee with can is happening
about every two weeks so I cannot wait
to see you on a future coffee with canel
show Jose I appreciate you St John
appreciate you Amanda appreciate you Eva
what is your skin routine oh man Keels
is what I've is is kind of where I'm
going all in these days I got that
Keels um oh Andrea drop a a v a link I
think they have an affiliate program
it'd be a different Channel obviously uh
but uh just can't end the stream just
totally
distracted uh I'm curious if they have
an affiliate program I'm scroll to the
bottom here R philosophy exclusive noce
collection okay K's
affiliate I'm not trying to promote him
here but I'm just curious yeah K's UK 8%
commission um do they have it in the
US okay K's affiliate program in the US
might be on a
phil. so I could sign up for that not my
Niche doesn't matter but there's like
this midnight recovery and then there's
like a something else or whatever so
that's appreciate the question uh I
turning 40 uh in um yeah kills is fire
in 27 days so anyways uh Hey appreciate
you Sean canel YouTube channel think
media podcast think media on a mission
help a million Purpose Driven people
create a full-time living doing what
they love will making a difference in
the world smash like if you haven't yet
and I will see you in a future episode
of the think media podcast or coffee
with canel